[Music]
by the grace of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars sh from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idy waiting to hit our Target of
2 million we have fully purchased four
properties in London transferred their
ownership to the W after the help of
Allah subhanahu wa taala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more updates now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in we are
here with how you do very good big man
what you saying alhamdulillah that's
good Aki it's nice to have you guys here
as usual so um got a bit of a cough but
hopefully this will not affect you
because you're going to laugh your heads
off yeah so obviously the good news is
that a couple of IDF soldiers will
liquidated as hijab will say on X or
being eaten by
maggots Munch up by mg or rejected
reject terminate terminate like they say
in Bosnia Margaret yes so this this is I
didn't know if I should laugh laugh or
cry in this mouth watch this so this is
them mourning the death of their brother
who's committing genocide there and they
are boldly actually saying what his
objectives were in Gaza so are you guys
ready for this try not to
[Music]
[Applause]
rapping you went there to kill women and
children bro in another one they go yeah
for fun he would are you sure that's not
acting or something no no no it's not
acting it's like a it's like they're
rapping it's like a rap SL mour bro you
can't make the stuff up yeah it's so
hilarious bro
like you entered Gaza to seek revenge on
as many women and children there is not
even men mentioned there they are boldly
bro this is unbelievable bro this is
like forget the way they're crying like
flipping absolute flipping yeah you can
see like cartoon not even cartoon but
what is it we something worse than that
what is it like squeaking like what is
this man it's like someone farting what
the hell is this forget this they are
clearly saying that your objective was
to go there and kill as many women and
children and the other comrad says yeah
when we first entered Gaza you burned
down a house and blew up a house have
you ever seen anything like this in
history bro has anyone ever come out and
boldly so
expressively we're out there for wom
children this is what we're here there
for no no no this is this is unique I
think for the Israelis they're the only
ones that have been protected
for I would say for
decades uh doing their crimes and
because they've got the backing of UK US
and the West in general um they are
actually deluded they're living in a
bubble they think everything goes their
way they can do whatever they want
however now things are taking a a
different turn and uh because of social
media because of uh the way human beings
communicate they are literally being
shown for what they are which is these
um these cringe people uh the satirical
people that honestly when you look at
you can you can't help but laugh laugh
at them uh you you can't feel sorry for
someone that says oh my my uh relative
died because they went to kill women and
children what how can anyone anyone with
a brain and a heart have sympathy for
clown like
this I mean it's terrible man like what
kind of savagery this is what you call
savagery what where do you think their
confidence comes from this is weird it's
like it's like they have Justified to
the S they have every right you know
before When The War start they said you
know we hate Hamas for them forcing us
to kill their kids yes where did you
think this false a is coming from
because yeah I think a lot of it comes
from the religion of Judaism actually um
because Judaism if you look at some of
talmudic you know references even the
Old Testament itself for instance in
depictions of is okay like a wild
individual and things like that you
could find that there's clearly an
entitlement schema yes that the children
of Israel have incurred or have um
preferred amongst themselves and I think
that if you if you think that you're the
you're better than everyone else as a
result of your tribe essentially that's
what it is it's not due to um you know
Merit it's not due to responsibilities
it's actually due to the fact that you
are of a particular tribe M and there's
enough uh information in Judaism in the
Old Testament in the talud to give
people that impression that is you could
say a normative position of Judaism okay
yeah then I think a lot of it comes from
that to be honest because it's not
something new with Zionism it's um this
entitlement schema yeah it's something
which existed for a very long time and
the Quran challenges it yeah for example
Allah mentions the Quran you know if you
are people in that uh if you are people
who think that you are
preferred above and beyond the other
people then ask for death you
know that they will never actually they
the ones that never yeah and then it
says
which means that you will find them most
cautious about protecting their own
life this is something and that they
will not be able to avert the punishment
the Quran I'm just translating the Quran
here that even if he lived for yeah yeah
they would wish to live a thousand years
yes death is going to overtake you yeah
and so I think a lot of the reason why
you find behavior of Jewish people
different to Christians and Muslims is
because of a eschatology they don't
believe in the same idea of afterlife
you know day of judgment Heaven and Hell
h b is because of the entitlement
complex which they could have uh you
know gotten from their texts because
it's a normative you know thing
interpretation of Judaism to believe
that you are preferred over the rest of
the people due to your
tribe and that's something the Quran
challenges that's the only way I can
understand this the studies in
psychology that show that if you um and
of course narcissism is an entire like
discussion and of itself right uh and I
I personally like the definition of Dr
malcin Who has a book called you know Dr
malcol Malin he wrote the book The N
test which is like NM is a sliding scale
but nevertheless the point is is that
there's many studies in uh psychology
which show that if you if you you know
raise a child to believe that he's
better than other children due to who he
is rather than what he does that he
grows up to be a narcissist wow so if
you if you raise an entire Community
with the same belief system this is what
then that's what you get this what you
get and I I believe like you know when
you look into the Quran Allah tells you
about you know what bani Isel done and
when Allah saved them from far and then
they end worshiping a golden calve and
then Allah sent down food from heaven
and they they had this weird challenging
attitude towards Allah and you're
thinking bro when you see this attitude
you read the Quran sometimes and you
know sometimes you're like bro were they
like were they that transgressing a when
you see what's going on you're like you
know what makes sense bro it makes sense
you know it just it's just this attitude
like who would be crying and say that
yes my brother went there to his
objective was revenge on women and
children you can't make this stuff up
man you can't make this stuff up you
have to have deep entitlement to believe
in that oh yes bro and no care for to
know that the whole world we watching
this and you carry this on like those
guys in the podcast saying he had a
button to destroy Gaza I will press it
now and if you asked any Israeli they
will say the same thing you can't make
this stuff up if you said it's five
people 10 people whatever but anyways
alhamd religion is far from this and it
doesn't teach and funnily enough the
iron the irony is that they think that
we endorse this kind of behavior Allah
has exposed it aldah but I just wanted
you guys to react to this absolute
morons and I hope they cry more more of
that comes inshah get eaten by maggots
whatever it is inshallah may Allah deal
with them more yes